the brotherly love between spider men
tobey maguire and andrew garfield and
you're telling me this friendship is the
real deal beyond the screen
fans went crazy the other day you and
toby mcguire went to a screening
together and they went nuts just for
that oh that's nice
what is it about his friendship that's
so special to you and could we see you
two do another project together i would
love to work with toby i mean like he's
such a great actor and he's a good buddy
and i really just love him and i would
love to make something with him for sure
before we get another collab from these
besties andrew's taking a dark turn in
his new hulu limited series under the
banner of heaven premiering next
thursday he plays a detective
investigating a murder in the lds church
what if this case isn't just a husband
who turned against his wife it is a true
crime thriller
that is dealing with some pretty dark
and heavy themes if you want to have a
glass of wine i'm not going to say you
shouldn't but whatever you want to do
whatever your poison
daisy edgar jones rory culkin and wyatt
russell co-star for russell playing a
church member meant a mini makeover you
had to lose the beard right did your
little one freak out no i don't i i
tried i did the thing where i was like
shave the beard and he was like he
didn't care
we have to ask where the crawdads thing
is coming out soon everybody went crazy
for the trailer you want me to pick from
my life
i won't reese witherspoon working on it
what's she like to work with i mean
she's so generous and lovely and
such an incredible like inspiration in
terms of you know
being an actor and also being a producer
and what she's done with that production
company and yeah very inspiring heads up
right now
of course you play one of the many
brothers you have some wonderful actor
brothers of your own could we ever see
the three of you do something together i
would love that you know someone finds
something for us to do and we'll do it
you